could billion-dollar drugs come out of
this process we got it out Diego Morales
is talking about je MJ's incubator in La
Jolla California
here are some 33 entrepreneurs are
working on everything including we're
making a product for acne we're trying
to come up with these new molecules
called RNA medicines to treat diseases
in a brand new way Todd Harris and Zach
Zimmerman are renting out lab space at
JJ's incubator where they get access to
millions of dollars of equipment that
startups usually can't afford Todd and
Zach don't work for J&J even though
they're working under the company's roof
there's no strings attached there's no
strings attached for me it was essential
that these was in no strings attached
model because he we made it with strings
attached
they wouldn't come Morello says they are
coming 400 companies have applied for
space in the J&J incubator since it
began in 2012 the entrepreneurs like
Todd and Zach though are free to sign
deals with other drug companies if they
want so why are you doing this we're
doing this because the traditional
business model for for large
pharmaceutical companies does not work
and it became clear the old model of
relying on in-house R&D to fill the
pipeline didn't work anymore especially
after J&J lost billions as a result of
patent expirations
the company realized it needed access to
additional sources for drug development
today J&J aggressively scans the globe
with Innovation Centers and incubators
which comb the scientific landscape for
ideas and projects now more than half of
J and J's drug development pipeline
comes from outside the company compared
with 20% more than a decade ago there
could be more J&J has looked at close to
2000 projects in the past year inking 61
deals from its innovation centers alone
what we're doing at wellspring is sort
of the Mount Everest of cancer drug
discovery troy wilson and ambitious
serial entrepreneur spent a year at the
J&J incubator before outgrowing the
space and moving out wilson has decided
to work with J&J to develop his drug to
treat a rare form of lung cancer we
wanted the resources and expertise of a
large pharma company and the reason we
went with J&J is this is a big hard
problem Paul Stoffels J&J chief
scientific
officer is counting on Wilson and other
startups to help solve the big hard
problems and if J&J gets to make money
in the process
all the better what's gonna be
considered a success rate for you one
significant product every second year is
this success rate you think that's what
will happen that's what will happen